welcome to this free webinar on
ngs data analysis today we will discuss
about the upcoming training program at
the various aspects of
rnac data analysis and how this field
of bioinformatics continues to evolve
this special program has been designed
for students faculty
and researchers in this program we will
focus
on one type of data which is
transcriptomics data
this program will cover analysis of gene
expression data
with practical sessions and online
tutorials
anyone with a basic knowledge of cell
and molecular biology
will be able to conceptually understand
as well as practically apply standard
data analysis tools
to process analyze and interpret complex
transcriptomics data
together we will study analytical
approaches for rna-seq data
using bioinformatics methods and
databases
we will be able to use rnac data to
study gene
and isoform expressions in various
organisms across many conditions
so the omics logic programs are a result
of close collaboration between pi and
biotech
and innovative big data and analytics
company based
in the us and numerous academic
institutions
that have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result the omits
logic programs have been thoroughly
tested around the world
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology
and biomedical studies majors as well as
faculty interested in bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
in the last omics logic transcriptomics
program which we had in 2020
many participants joining us were able
to successfully
complete the program and the feedback
shared by these participants are
encouraging for
our team as well as those who continue
to take these courses
the participant feedback also
demonstrates
that the learning is effective and even
transformational
the training is offered using and
leveraging the regular online webinars
like we're having today
practical exercises and online courses
these resources
provide a broad and detailed overview
of processing statistical analysis
machine learning tools and single cell
data analysis techniques
the courses cover methods expand on
various terminologies provide
practical examples and offer quizzes for
self evaluation while we use the server
platform for running
pipelines and the codemix logic platform
for learning more about
rn python and its utility in
understanding
bioinformatics data my name is biksha
bhaswas and i am the omixlogic community
manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
who are part of our community before i
introduce everyone to the team behind
omix logic
and today's session speakers we would
like to know more about you
so right now on your screen you will see
a poll
so here are a few questions what we want
to learn
from you about your understanding of ngs
so the first question is
what are your interests in learning ngs
data analysis
and you can choose from the four
different
options that you see on your screen
the second question is what research
area i'm sorry it's written where
what research area you want to apply ngs
transcriptomics data analysis to
so these are a few areas if you see that
there is an answer and you would want to
apply to any other area which i have not
mentioned beyond
these four please put them down in the
chat box so that we are aware
that the different research areas you
are interested in
so i see that a lot of you are
interested in precision oncology
very interesting as well as infectious
diseases so how much time will you be
able to dedicate for the ngs data
analysis training per week
okay so i think we are having six to
eight hours is the highest number
and what ngs data analysis research you
are familiar with
so there's single cell transcriptomics
non-coding rna
mrna and i'm a beginner and would like
to learn more
okay so i see that today we have a lot
of you who are just starting out
with learning about ngs data analysis
which is interesting and we will be
covering some of these
important aspects as well so i'll just
leave on
this poll for one more minute and then
we'll move ahead with the presentation
so if you have not yet answered please
go ahead with the poll and i'll be
ending the poll in a minute
okay thank you everybody
i'm honored to have been working with a
team
that collectively have amazing
experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has
a long standing recognition for his
generous support of many
international projects and research
activities one of these projects is the
establishment of the tower
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
here at buying biotech
and here you can meet the other members
of our team
as well as dr leonid brodsky
in the upcoming one-month period you
will have the opportunity to
interact and collaborate with an
international team of
experts specialized in the areas of
bioinformatics and data driven research
let me introduce you to the program
mentors
we have dr harpreet kaur who is our
omics logic trainer and expert
bioinformatician and she will mentor
sessions and guide
participants throughout the programs
her area of specialization is in cancer
genomics we will be hearing more from dr
cord today dr mohit mazumdar has a phd
in computational biology and over 10
years of experience working with
industrial academia
elia brodsky is our ceo and co-founder
his experience in research in academia
has led to many
research labs and university
collaborations and has been recognized
for the simplified
approach to omits analysis for education
now i would like to invite dr mazumdar
to talk more about rna-seq analysis
and ngs data thank you dr muzumdar over
to you
yeah thank you biepcha let me share my
screen
hello everyone and thank you for joining
this specialized session on
bioinformatics or mixed logic technology
my name is mohit mazumdar and in my
current role i'm working and
collaborating with universities in asia
and africa
to introduce innovative curriculums on
data driven biological research
at different level of education so
during this short period i've been
honored to be able to collaborate and
work with thousands of students and
researchers
around the globe so this free webinar
is conducted for participants and
especially students and researchers and
faculty in
india and neighboring countries we have
invited
all who have shown interest in learning
about
ngs transcriptomics data analysis and
research
using our research program and platforms
in the context of the upcoming program
the online training is a unique
opportunity
not to not only learn about
ngs transcriptomics but to master data
science skill sets
and apply to an original research
project
in in within two months of training so
let's
learn about this exciting field of
research so beepsha
i am facing an issue with uh
slight transitions because i think the
host co-hosting thing so can you check
that
so as i was telling you that let's start
with
learning about this technology and to do
that
i mean let's answer a few questions so
molecular biologists study a broad
spectrum of topics
related to regulations of cell biology
from dna and rna to protein expression
and then protein protein interactions so
next generation sequencing is a key
technology
that is enabling which is enabling us at
an unprecedented level of
precision and efficacy
in understanding genomic and
transcriptomic
regulations so a next generation
a next generation sequencer creates a
digital file
right and that digital file represents a
sequence
dna or rna so this file
contains information where nucleotides
are
represented by letters
corresponding to their bases right so a
dominant theme
in molecular biology is how
variation how variation in nucleic acid
which is the genotype affects the
biology of the organism which is the
phenotype so a second major theme
in the study of gene expression and this
resulting chain
is observed transcriptomics features of
a studying
uh studying sample so what what is a
transcriptomic feature of a studying
sample
so in next generation sequencing data
analysis
where we call it like rna-seq a lot of
time
the purpose of this analysis is to map
the short reads from raw sequencing
files
to the reference genome and then study
the abundance of rna mapped to a
particular region
so this abundance can represent the
level of
gene or the isoform expression
and then it can be compared between
samples
or group of samples so that is uh
an overview about uh transcriptomics
and rna sequencing
so i'm still facing issue with the
transition
so in today's workshop uh we will start
with
big biological data and the high
throughput sequencing processes
uh which are focused on rna-seq ngs
data so to know more about uh this today
in the session we will go through
transcriptomics resources
uh then we will be talking about the
mentor support
and we will be demonstrating you and
demonstrate to you the
explanation of methods using multi-omics
tibia info platform
so one of the major objective of this
entire you know methodology starting
from the courses
training support and then learning the
techniques
so this the major objective of this
research training
is to enable the participants to prepare
for
real-world application of rna-seq and to
be able to apply
training to a research project so the
uh how the overall project
works it can be summarized in a few
steps
so let me tell you about a few few steps
that we can take
to work on a project so how how does it
actually works
so it can start from you know framing a
problem which could be like a title of
your project
and then ident identifying a data set so
that data set uh
actually represents the research that
you're interested in it could be
agriculture like many of you have shown
interest
that was there in the poll that in
agriculture
applying it in agriculture and
biomedical research
or any other kind of research so
from identifying a data set and the
references
to preparing the data next step is to
prepare the data
process the data for analysis and then
perform the analysis
so once your data is prepared the next
step would be to perform your analysis
and do uh go in depth of that what what
you are finding
so whether your process that process
that you're following is statistically
correct
and logical and then you're trying to
interpret the results
so uh in this uh today's webinar
uh and as we are speaking about this
uh we will be having dr harpreet god in
a
short time to talk more about applying
ngs transcriptomics
uh research in translational how it is
how it is playing a key role in
translational research which is uh
boom in the biomedical industry
so now let me show you the design and
the curriculum
of the first four week of the training
for first four weeks of the training
so the program uh will kick off on
second march uh 2021
and uh on the session on that day we'll
feature the orientation
orientation session with our omics logic
trainer dr harpreet kaur myself
as the project man mentor and along with
that
along with us miss biebs abiswas and the
team of interns and research fellows
so during the first week we will learn
about
we will learn about uh processing of
gene expression
then we will learn about alternative
splicing
and then we will learn about assays for
mrna detection and quantification so
after
completing the introduction to next
generation sequencing
for study uh to study the rna expression
next we will learn about quantitative
and qualitative analysis of
rna in a sample and then data
preparation
using next generation sequencing and
preparation of
table of expression uh from raw fast q
files
so all of our omics logic training kind
of
includes resources so these resources
are assigned to
each sessions to help student make the
most out of this training
so in this first
session we will be introducing you to a
lot of resources
so this omixlogic program
leverages our top-rated online tutorials
that are present
in this educational platform
so that includes uh so the program
participants
will have the access exclusive resources
that are assigned
for each session um uh that uh
are associated with the training so
along with this
there is a smart tracking of activity
and there are curated data sets uh
biological data
data sets that are designed for a great
learning experience
so after this we will be talking about
the analytical platform
so this program
and throughout this course
you will be given directions to access
the
tb info platform and i don't know if you
guys are able to see the animation so we
have to fix this picture can you just
sign out and uh like sign in with with
your own login
website can you hear me
okay sorry for this uh let's just
try to figure this out because
uh-huh i still have an issue
so just uh for a second let me uh
log in again so the slide transitions
can be smooth because each time i'm
doing the transition it's
getting stuck so there are no animations
that could be played
with this so just let me sign in
and join again
so dr harpreet you're there yes yes i am
okay dr harpreet so i am making you the
host
and i'm going to join again all right
okay
okay
so beeps i have made your co-host yeah
thank you
okay okay so
can you see it see my screen now yeah
yes okay perfect so
as i was telling you that uh throughout
this course uh we will be sending you
the directions
directives to access the t-bind for
platform so the t-pan for platform
have uh the processing area and analysis
area for rna-seq data so the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipeline
and different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
it's a quite comprehensive platform
which is used for
various sort of trainings we are
conducting oncology specialization
trainings
we are conducting um infectious disease
specialized
specialization trainings so these are
some of the uh
panels i have been um collaboratively
um worked out with universities like uh
ucsf
who uh with whom we have developed this
virology section
and so as you see there are several
sections here so
in this program our focus will be on the
transcriptomic section
so in this transcriptomic sections
section we will learn about
first we will learn about the data
processing and then
we will be using the section under data
mining
and we will there we will be learning
about different algorithms
um which machine learning algorithms and
uh classification
uh algorithms that that are going to
help us
understand the meaning out of this big
omics data
and again like when we are integrating
multiple data sets like you talk about
uh the non-coding rnas and
uh mrna and then uh on other omics data
then we have
a dedicated section for multi-omics
integration as well
which is quite popular and gives a lot
of uh
insights that we were not been able to
get gain
before so um and then
we will be using so the other platform
that you saw
the tbi info platform that does not
require
any coding require you to do any coding
so you can learn
from a visual environment and learn
about the logic
of the analysis so the focus here is to
learn about the logic
that why these steps are used and what
are the
standard output from an uh popular
algorithms that are used for
rna-seq experiments and we will be
learning more about it
when dr harpreet uh takes you there so
we'll be
doing that in a in some time but to tell
you more about that how we are utilizing
this
in a synchronous way so that you
gain a deeper understanding of how this
sort of analysis
is done and applied in current research
so you start with the understanding of
the theory
and then we go into the practical
aspects of
uh doing the experiment and then uh
after doing the experiment
we would want to do a visualization and
we would want to do some downstream
analysis
so we have exercises designed to explain
the codes
for these types of visualization in both
r
and python that will be used in this
program
so along with that uh we will be sending
you the video tutorials
and these video tutorials
different aspects of you know uh whether
we are going to
want to uh install python whether we
want to you know
do it on the on the platform whether how
do we want to you know learn about the
different sections of the platform
so all those are uh already available
and video recorded tutorials with us
and we will be sharing those with our
participants when we
start the program so after that
the first introductory week where we
will be sharing you about the platform
getting you more familiarized with the
resources
and you are comfortable about you know
exploring
and uh going to the platform and having
your own profile
then the next week uh the next class
on march 5th we will start with the
analysis
and um to talk about the analysis
um we will be doing after gaining a
basic understanding
we will start with a data set so there
is a significant
interest in sequencing especially
in the context of oncology and that is
due to its potential
to advance diagnostics and personalized
treatment
so that that added with that
there is an improvement on understanding
of
the treatment responses and the cause
and mechanism of tumor development
so all of these things are contributing
in
precision oncology so in this session
using a breast cancer
data set we will review we will be
reviewing methods
how to how data is generated using next
generation sequencing
and use a sample project patient
derived xenograft transcriptomics
biomarkers for breast cancer to practice
generating a table of expression from
raw fastq files
so uh from a publication uh that is
uh the data which is being published and
submitted in a ncbi bio project
we will be using that data set and we
will be giving you the publication
and we will be having this session to
describe that and we will
start working on the data and
understanding uh of how
from raw data you can generate a table
of
expression so
in addition to the online courses uh
obviously all the participants will get
access to the hands-on exercises and
data sets for practice
uh these can be completed without any
coding so this will be by using the
t-bind for platform
that will give you an interactive
learning experience
so talking about the transcriptomic
sequencing
so this is a transcriptomics pipeline
that
has a number of algorithms that you can
see so transcriptomic sequencing
is a major advance in the study of gene
expression in the field of study of gene
expression
because it allows a snapshot of whole
transcriptome
rather than a predetermined set of genes
so before that it was microarray we have
panels uh then we have set of genes
which were biomarkers now we can look at
the
entire transcriptome at a given point of
time to study this data
right it's a lot of data to study this
data we will
learn about processing pipelines so this
is a processing pipeline
a processing pipeline that turns raw
reads
means the reads that are coming from a
sequencing machine
into structured data that which is ready
for analysis so this platform is color
coded
uh color coded means that section wise
you can uh
um you know um differentiate
that which section is for which kind of
analysis
so this helps to establish a logical
connection
between uh theoretical aspects of data
analysis methods
and the practical steps that are needed
to achieve a
biologically interpretable result
so the pipeline outputs that we get so
once you get uh
once you are done with your once you run
your analysis
and once you get uh from a table from
rod
sequence to a table of expression
so the pipeline outputs are offered as
tables
uh graphics and interactive
visualization
helping users to understand the way data
can
be used to uh you know explore or
understand a biological phenomena
so we will also learn to preview and
visualize
uh the resulting data using principal
component analysis
so this is a very popular algorithm
which is a machine learning algorithm
which is used to visualize
uh high dimensional data
multi-dimensional data
so two per to perform the example
analysis
uh this will be uh also
uh provided that is also provided in the
course student will need to have the
access of the tbi info platform to
to do the assignment and then you will
get all these sort of uh
um hands-on practical uh aspect of doing
the
analysis so in this uh
entire training we will also be using
microsoft excel
or any other uh software equivalent
software
for plotting so this would
also require us to go to some of the
ncbi for example this is a jbrowse where
you can visualize
the alignment in much more detail
so after doing all of this in the first
week
the second week we will be learning
about
data preparation using ngs and getting
the table of expression from
raw fascia files so in the next session
we will review
important topics and keywords that are
associated with
rnac transcriptomics analysis so in this
session
we will learn about working with table
of expression
to get a high level view of rna-seq data
and
the participants then will get their
first hands-on assignment
in this session on the patient-derived
xenograph data set
and we will also be sharing additional
resources
reading material for all the algorithms
that you saw there
in transcriptomics one so this will be
also a review session and an interactive
session
to know if you have any problems or if
you have any confusion
if you are getting somewhere stuck so
things like that
and um after this in this week
we will start exploring the basic coding
so for those who are interested in
coding can
uh are could join this
and we will be able to do this coding in
our code
platform so uh in this
we will be doing uh from loading data
to some of the downstream analysis so
basically it would be a very basic
overview of
how to export files and how to
load that data using the code platform
so this week we will be learning how to
visualize summarize and analyze data
from
processing pipeline so uh in
transcriptomics like starting from
march 12th on march 12th it will be will
be trans
move will be moving from you know uh
table of expression and the basic
analysis to more
statistical analysis so this
transcriptomics 2
would be more about you know
understanding at a statistical level
that how
your data is i mean what your data says
and what is the what are the noise
how we can remove the noise and find the
meaning out of those
uh out of that
out of the experiment that we have got
so one of the limitations
in this sort of high speed data
generation
is the amount of noise and amount of
um you know non-essential data that we
get
so one of the key uh
key skills that comes from this sort of
experience
is to be able to uh learn about
your data and visualize it when you have
generated it
so that your downstream analysis makes
sense so some of these techniques
are used to study the variation
so we will be using gene expression
matrix then you can
that can be used to study the variation
so some of these techniques
are really easy it's not that tough some
of these techniques are easy to use
and can be done in excel and we'll be
going through that in our sessions
and which will be recorded and sent out
via email
so we will be using either excel or some
table manipulation software
and some of the other approaches which
are
more streamlined approaches those will
be used
using the tbi info cloud
so in transcriptomics 2 during this this
week
we will be learning about more complex
algorithms and we will be using some of
the statistical algorithms like t-test
and then the um the online session
that will supplement this course
transcriptomics 2 module
it describes a number of statistical
techniques typically
used for simpler and then more complex
approaches to find
differentially expressed genes so
once the data is you know standardized
and
prepared we will learn about what about
working the identify
genes to arrive at a biological
interpretation of results
so ultimately it's not just about the
data
but also how to prepare it we want to
gain a biological
uh you know in our objective here is to
gain a
understanding or a biological
understanding of the project
so connecting the data elements with
their biological significance
will be a major focus of this program so
in the week
in the third week when we have this
understanding of how statistics work
what is there to look into the data we
will be focusing on differential gene
expression
so one of the major objective of doing
transcriptomics research
is sometimes and most of the time is to
learn about the differential gene
expression
and uh we will be continue we'll
continue to look and
look at typical challenges that can be
resolved
using other methods so we will use a t
test then we will use
d62 to run a differential gene
expression pipeline
and then we will use uh in the next
session
we will learn about the first machine
learning method
which is the factor regression analysis
so it's a regression based algorithm
so in this session uh after
doing this after learning this as a
result you will be able to detect
obvious differences between preset
groups
as well as the expand the idea of more
subtle differences presented by factors
that might interact with each other so
when i'm talking about multi-dimensional
data
then uh you will see that that
data has multiple features so if you
get a data for for example for a liver
cancer
sample then you will you might find that
that there are
uh there are different factors that
influences liver cancer so it's not
so simple that uh there is a direct
connection but there are multiple
factors that
influences one connection and to
understand about that
the statistical analysis that will be
used is factor regression analysis
so uh as i was telling you that we will
be working on data sets throughout this
throughout this program so we'll discuss
the property of such data sets where
thousands of
observations about each sample
contributes to noise
and misleading data some aspects of log
normal distribution
and adjusted p value they are accounted
for
false discovery rate will be explained
in detail
so for our next session on friday march
19th that will be dedicated to advance
analytical methods advanced analysis
methods of transcriptomics data
that allows us to find meaningful
pattern in big data sets
especially complex patterns that are
very typical for
rna-seq experiments for example i mean
pca pca can help us understand
variability between samples
by analyzing all of our data features so
we can use such dimensionality reduction
techniques
to get a better better insight better
insights
into our data set and to be able to
visualize it
so by comparing multiple methods and by
plotting them
we will also learn about
uh we can study genes so as a result we
can study genes
and how they describe how the how they
are described in samples
so samples are maybe the patient samples
in our data set
and how this correlates with phenotypic
information we have for biological
or even clinical interpretation
so we will learn about impact of feature
selection on interpretation of
conditions
sampled on various data sets
so after exploring different methods for
identifying
groups of samples without prior
knowledge so when we
don't have a prior knowledge we call it
unsupervised machine learning
and when we have a prior knowledge we
call it supervised machine learning
so one of the example of unsupervised
machine learning is clustering
so in week 4 we will examine methods for
developing
classifiers for known samples
which is predictive analysis or
classification
so in the next week after learning about
unsupervised machine learning
we will be learning about approaches
such as
machine learning and data mining and
predictive analysis
using algorithms to to learn about how
they connect
and how they give us what important
information that we are asking from the
data set
so to do that we will cover uh decision
trees and random forest to work with
various
gene sets for classification for example
a defined pattern of expression can be
linked to you know regulatory network
affected by a condition so this could be
one of the things that you get
out of this sort of research so for
example we will
learn to utilize gene set expression and
gene set enrichment analysis
to find pathways or genes that enriched
which are like either upregulated or
down regulated and are
are genes of our interest so
during this entire exercise of learning
about machine learning algorithms you
will be learning about dimensions
classes and features which are helping
us
understand how these machine learning
algorithms can be
applied to offer interpretable results
so application wise after learning after
you saw this is like a journey you start
from basic
understanding basic data analysis then
you transfer
then you move uh towards the second
area to more advanced statistical
analysis and then you move to a further
advanced analysis of
using machine learning and now that how
this entire research field can be
applied to various areas of uh
research so sorry
so these methods are not always used in
smaller research projects
however they have much more important
application
in both pharma and biotech r d
as well as in clinical applications so
mastering these methods
will help you understand for example
in clinical application or in biomedical
research you can think about biomarker
discovery
and patient stratification both of which
uses
uh predictive modeling and feature
selection
so here today uh we have a very
uh specialized person dr harpreet car
with us
who she has done her entire phd and have
published
amazing papers on some of the aspects of
ngs data and machine learning
so now i'd like to uh pass it on to
dr harpreet to guide us and talk more
about
bioinformatics projects and application
of ngs data
and that that what we will be doing in
the second phase
of this training uh in the week five
onwards so over to you dr harpreet
thank you doctor and yeah please feel
free
to ask questions regarding whatever i
have shared
so i'll be happy to answer them in the
chat and we will have a q a session
towards the end as well
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics in my
current role i am omics logic
bioinformatics
trainer with bind biotech i am assisting
participants to learn
about data analysis machine learning and
visualization in the application to the
last data set
used in the biomedical research beside i
am involved in designing different
research projects
using publicly available data
so the upcoming omics logic program will
be focused on transcriptomics
we will discuss the various aspects of
rna-seq data analysis
and how this field can be
applied to the various suspect and
continuously growing
in the health care so during this
program
you will learn about how you can design
your own
independent research project based on
publicly available ngs transcriptomics
data
and employing various bioinformatics
techniques
so today we will perform various ngs
data analysis
using the data sets based on basin drive
genograph project so now let's
understand
what is a pdx project or pdx model
so a pdx models are generated when a
fresh tumor
fresh tissue obtained directly from the
patient
and is implanted subcutaneously and
ortho topically
into the immune deficient mice so as
these models maintain the principle
histological clinical and molecular
characteristics of the original patient
tumor samples
while remaining biologically stable
since these pdx models are more closely
resemble
and recapitulate the the tumor growth in
human
than standard in vitro cell line so they
remain
key experimental platform for
pre-clinical drug development
so today we will try to analyze
two breast cancer subtypes using pdx
model
the breast cancer types include ear
positive
and triple negative so this year
positive
uh breast cancer have a special type of
receptor that is estrogen receptors
while the triple negative breast cancer
lacks
all the three common receptor on its
membrane
so this is just a one difference that
makes
triple negative is a more aggressive
form of breast cancer
while year remains a more treatable form
so now let's go over to the server and
let's run an example pipeline
here we will learn how we can generate a
gene expiration
well structured gene expression data
table from
raw sequencing read data
so let's move over move over t band for
server
so bifsa if you share this
okay thank you
so on this interface you will find
various sections for different types of
analysis
like already dr mohit has shown you we
have ngs data analysis then mass spec
analysis then structure biology
then data integration and
modeling so under the ng uh ngs data
section
here we have a subsection that is
dedicated to the transcriptomics
so once you are on this server so here
you will find a different analysis
pipeline
so today i am going to demonstrate a
simple example pipeline
that is from the pdx project so on
here under the rna seq sequential
parallel analysis of ngs and microarray
data
here if we click on the drop down you
will get this demo
rnac pdx project so
i'm clicking on this as this is a
demonstration pipeline so we have
already
uploaded example data set that is raw
sequencing data so by clicking on
the start we will able to
upload this data so here we have already
provided the reference genome file and
as well as
we have created the sql links for the
fastq
files and we have submitted that files
here
and once we click on ok be able to
submit upload these files so then the
next option that is getting
highlighted that is under the
preprocessing
so the next option which getting
highlighted here is trimomatic so what
it does
it will removes adapters from your raw
sequencing read data
so eventually it will remove all the
non-technical sequence
and we are come up with only read
sequences
so then the next step which is getting
highlighted here that is pcr clean
so what this pcr clean will do that
it will going to remove your pcr
duplicates
as during uh before uh
during the generation of rna seek
analysis
so we used to uh done the pcr
amplification
so it will remove all the pcr duplicates
so then the next options that are
getting alignment once you got the clean
deeds
then next is how you are going to
align your reads against a reference
genome
or reference transcriptome as here our
goal
is to generate a gene expression data
table
from the rnec so we are
mapping our reads against a
transcriptome
so for that we are using this mapping
algorithm that is but i
2t
so here what it does it will align your
reads against the reference
transcriptome
by clicking on ok we will execute that
step
then up after the mapping of a reads on
a reference transcript
next is quantification of your reads
so here we are using this rscm
expression algorithm
so with this algorithm we will able to
generate a gene expression table on
which you can perform various kind of
uh analysis so this particular rscm
which is also known as
rna-seq using expectation maximization
algorithm so this software will
eventually quantify
your expression in the form of ftkm
rpkm or tpm depending upon your input
rates
so then here i am also executing the
another analysis that is differential
gene expression analysis so once we will
have a gene expression table then we can
also perform differential gene
expression and this is
so here we have different algorithm
right now i am using the dsec2
so it will perform the differentially
expression analysis between the
these two condition that is er positive
and triple negative breast cancer type
so then we can and this pipeline by
clicking on it we will able to complete
this pipeline
so once your pipeline will get completed
then under the download pipeline output
files you will get here all the outputs
so the first output that i am going to
show you that is
how the gene expression table
so let me just download this gene
expression table
so this is the gene expression table
that we have obtained after running this
dsec pipeline
so let me just paste it in the excel so
now we have
this gene expression table where our
samples
are in the columns while in the row we
have
ensemble ids for the transcripts again
for the genes
so here you will get like year positive
sample then you will have at the end you
will have a triple negative sample
so this is the first outcome that we
have obtained after running this
pipeline where we have obtained
gene expression table in the form of pkm
values
where you can perform various kind of
analysis so then
the second output that we have obtained
if you have observed
as we had also also executed desect
analysis
so we will also get the uh output for
that
so if you download this folder that is
desect all pipe chips
so then we will able to obtain
this folder so here you will have a
different output so the first output i
would like to show you
that is
this table desect table the results from
the dsec analysis
as dr mohit has already shown you that
the most important thing point is
identifying the important
genes that can differentiate between two
different conditions so this is what the
table we will obtain
so like here we have
first in the first row we have genes
then we have the in the third row like
here
we have log to fold chains then in the
last column we have p
adjusted value so then we can identify
only important significant genes by
filtering out
these genes by based on the p adjusted
value
so uh the significant the p value which
is considered as significant
that is p value less than point zero
five so you then you can filter out only
important chain
so this is the one another analysis that
you can run
so apart from the differential gene
expression analysis
and the uh obtaining the table
so once we have this gene expression
table
so the other analysis that we can
perform that is we should
able to to normalize this data
so this is what the kind of gene
expression table that we have obtained
after running the this rna-seq pipeline
so during this program you will learn
various uh how you can
execute various exploratory data
analysis
but to perform any explorative data
analysis your expression
data must be normalized so as it is well
known fact that
most of the statistics methods can be
applied on a data
that follow normal distribution so when
looking at like
original data here the uh of this
a large number of samples will be look
like outliers
so this type of distribution will
interfere with many of the statistical
tests
or machine learning algorithm analysis
so to reduce this wide range of variance
uh variation
we need to perform normalization of the
data
so like after applying the normalization
we can actually derive
a significant meaning from this data so
thus we will learn about different
methods
to normalize transcript transcriptomics
data
like log scale transformation or the
quantile normalization
so next to understand the pattern of the
distribution of the sample within our
data
we can perform various types of
exploratory data analysis
so there are number of the exploratory
data analysis
available like number of the
unsupervised as well as supervised
algorithm
so let me demonstrate how you can
perform principle com
component analysis as well as quantile
normalization
on your data once you have a table using
this simple
t band for platform so let let me go
again
on t band for server
so here under the air area analysis we
can again directly to the
first interface so here under the data
mining you will find different
options like supervised unsupervised
utility factor analysis
then differential gene expression
analysis so as i am interested to
perform
quantile normalization as well as pca so
i am taking the example of this
demo utility pca
so here already we have uploaded this
data
uh that we have obtained from the
rna-seq pipeline
so then by clicking on ok be able to
upload this data
then the next step is quantile
normalization
so then here we are mainly executing two
steps first we are converting our
uh fpkm value into the log scale and
then we are transforming these value
into the uh quantile normalized using a
threshold five
so we are clicking on that okay
be able to perform quantile
normalization once we have normalized
data now we can
perform various exploratory data
analysis so right now i am performing
principal component analysis
that is pca so by clicking on
ok be able to perform that by ending
be able to complete this pipeline so
here
under the output we will get these
results let me just show you this pc
plot results
similarly
so here so these are this plot ways we
can draw later as well
so here we have obtained the pca
components like here the first
component here it contribute nearly 30
variation in the data
then the pca2 pca2 component that
contribute nearly
14 variation in the data so by taking
this
uh these two components we can draw a
pca plot or scatter plot
sorry
just give me a second
so then we can draw a scatter plot to
understand the pattern
so like this one so then we can actually
go
mark them and plot something like this
so here based on the pca plot we can
visualize
the difference between the two classes
of the sample
that is er positive and triple negative
besides because this particular data set
also have mice models that is a timing
and the not
so we can draw the pattern for that as
well
so this is how you can draw pca plot
simply using this pca
pipeline and then the next platform
apart from that but our script coding
how this
scripts are working behind so then we
have the another platform
that is codomics logic so if you are on
this platform here under the courses you
will find different courses
how each of these scripts work so the
for example
first i am going through the one of the
pca
pipeline so here in the course you will
find the different lessons
for each type of analysis like data
visualization
then dimensionality reduction then
differential gene expression analysis
and clustering as well
so if i go to the one of this lesson
that is dimensionality reduction by pca
so in this each of these lesson you will
find a different subsections
so here the first step will provide
give you the detailed introduction like
what you are going to perform
so then in the once you able to complete
that
in the second part that is learn the
code here you will
learn how this script is working so how
you can write your own code so what each
step is doing you will
get that information so once you're able
to learn this code
in the next section you will
you will try it yourself so for example
i am taking
this pc plot here first we are loading a
libraries that is a required
package then we are loading our data
each step
is written with the hash exactly but the
next step is doing
so then we are taking only the data that
contain
without only numerical data so then we
have performed
a piece principal component analysis
using prc com function
so then once be able to perform pca then
how we can plot for example first we are
going to perform simple pca plot
then we are also creating uh we also
adding colors
then we are also adding the frames and
then you can also add the
labels that is what are these samples so
by clicking on run
you can you able to execute this code
so like here we have obtained different
plots so let me just show you like this
is with this example data
so the first you will get like plot like
this where you can
how your samples are distributed
so then you can also draw up
frames against each of these subtypes
like here we have different groups
like this is from the breast cancer cell
line data which
have four breast cancer subtypes that is
basal chlorine low luminal and normal
life
so how we can visualize the differences
between
these samples so this pc plot will help
you to do that
so on codomics you will learn to execute
code so then under
another section where you can modify
these codes according to
your own analysis so
now let's let me go back to the
presentation
so this is how you can generate your pca
plots
so this is about the codomix platform
so the in the last week to provides
hands-on training
and to make participants familiar with
the approach to design
and complete a research project we are
continuously designing different
research projects using publicly
available data
based on a studies published in high
impact journals thus we have a
collection of research projects
where you can learn how bioinformatics
can be applied in the field of
various fields of
health care using publicly available
data to drive
biological and clinical important
signatures
so let me give you an example of the
liver cancer project
here we have explored different omics
data types that is rna
and miuranian clinical uh clinical and
demographic data
employing multi multi-omics data
integration approach
for the liver cancer patient to find out
the molecular signature that are
associated with
clinical phenotypes of the liver cancer
patients
as one of the major challenge with this
malignancy
is that a single omics data is not
sufficient to design
high highly efficient biomarker thus
multi omics data types can fill up that
lacuna
and will facilitate to design efficient
signatures
but then another major challenge is the
integration of those multi-omics data
types
either you need to develop an individual
pipeline for each data type
then you will find an approach or a
method to integrate them together
for this you required high computational
and bioinformatics
skills so to remove those obstacles
various multiomics data integration
tools like snf
i cluster plus go to pls on a t band for
server but integrated peer users just
need to provide input data set
and can easily perform various types of
multi-omics analysis by just clicking on
options as i have shown you
in demonstration so in this project
we have also used these multi-omics data
tools
to find out important signatures
so finally we uh we have fire
we have tried to multi omics data
integration that can provide us
holistic picture of this lethal
malignancy and how the
how they are associated with diverse
clinical phenotype like
tumor stage risk factors is gender of
the patients
so participant can explore this project
beside
we have another project on covid19
so in this project you will explore
about this pathogen corona virus itself
as well as the disease caused by it
then you will learn about its origin and
how much it is related with already
existing human coronavirus streams
using ngs data and bioinformatics
methods
next you will also see what important
components of the virus through which
they enter into the human cell
and finally you will see how you can
identify important transcriptomic
signatures that can
significantly different or significantly
different under
therapeutic treatment and untreated
conditions
then you will also get an project over
alzheimer's disease
so as we know alzheimer is one of uh is
a complex neurodegenerative disease
caused by several genetic
and epigenetic factor so these are
driven by
genetic variations changes in the gene
expression as well as the
other omics data types so here you will
learn
on this project you will learn how you
can obtain a data from
data set from public repository and
execute different types of analysis
so in the later part of this training
program you will
need to submit a research proposal so
here you need to define various
fields like project title that is your
research questions
then you have to define you need to
define your exact research
statement then you need to provide
project summary that you need to define
what is your expected outcome
and then what are what are the different
method methods that you can employ
and then you need to provide the data
set that you can use
and as well as the reference
publications
so in the past there are number of the
research fellows
who have completed their research
projects in the diverse fields
based on ngs transcriptomics
bioinformatics with the pine biotic
research fellowship program so among
them
one of our research for fellow mr
kalaumari maril who is a phd student
from
mexico city he has recently completed
his research project
entitled classification of triple
negative breast cancer cell line
by gene expression analysis of the
transmembrane protein
using various types of machine learning
algorithm
that are avail integrated on t band
first server
and based on available cell line data
employing these tools
then we have another research we had
another research
research fellow miss semi dollar a
undergraduate student
student from the turkey recently
completed her research project
entitled long non-coding rna as
therapeutic target
in chronic lymphocyte leukemia using
publicly available data
from cll and employing different tools
from the t bind for server
so i am looking forward to become a
research
trainer and i now i would like to pass
this session
to miss bipsa to talk about registration
process
and more about this program so over to
you beeps are
thank you so much dr harpreet
so let me introduce you to the different
program resources as well as some of the
free resources
we have for all of our participants that
you can start
learning from right away so for
different parts of this one month
program we leverage our mix logic
resources
that will include the asynchronous
courses as dr mohit
has shown the cloud-based analytical
server where you can analyze
large rna-seq data as well as visualize
the results
as dr hartwick was demonstrating to you
the omics logic code breakdown where you
can practice coding in rn python as well
as a repository of
project examples so to do this the first
platform that we have is the
ut buying for platform and let us
together
go and see this platform so please come
with me to edu.t hyphen bio dot info
so in this platform this is a free login
and once you log into this platform you
will have a membership
to the free resources for a lifetime so
this is the edut by input platform and
here is a free resource
that if you have not already taken i
would invite you all to go ahead it's
the introduction to bioinformatics
course
and this course will introduce you to
the different
areas of application of bioinformatics
so if you are someone who is new to
our bioinformatics community we invite
you all to go ahead
and take this course this course will
give you an
overview and it starts with an
introductory survey
this survey is very helpful for us to
understand what are your
areas of research interest and where do
you want to go forward with the kind of
bioformatics training you're looking for
so please go through this course if you
have not already taken it
and help us learn more about you and
talking about what dr harpreet has
already shown you
as part of this program as part of the
omits logic training
addition to the courses you have access
to different projects right so
here is a project on tuberculosis that
manisha has been asking about
so you can see so these projects are
available to all participants or part of
the omics logic programs
if you want to take this project as you
see there is a cost
for uh for the projects to be taken if
you're doing them
separately but for all participants of
any of our programs
many of these projects are included
depending on the kind of comics logic
training
you are going through so there are
different projects here
on ebola on cancer that we will be
taking examples for in this one month
training
and the next step as doctor herpet shows
is to come up with your own project
proposal
so as this is a one month training we
understand there is not
enough time to come up with a full
fledged project
but what we would hope and we help
help you do is come up with your own
project proposal
and i'm going to be sharing with you
some examples so these are
examples from people and participants
who have taken
these kinds of projects and done it
themselves
so these were all done in our research
fellowship program which is the next
step
where once you complete a training
program the next step is to develop your
own research project
so all of these projects that you would
find on this page
has been proposed by the participants
and then
they have worked very closely with our
mentor
team to work on these projects
so you will see different examples from
participants
who come from different levels of
education so we have
high school students who are doing these
projects as
well as we have phds and post doctorates
who are doing these kinds of projects
utilizing
public domain data sets for different to
answer different kinds of biological
questions so you're welcome to go
through this free resource
and going back so what do you gain at
the end of this
one month training program you will
receive a certificate so we give out
two different certificates here is an
example of a certificate of
excellence which was given to one of our
participants from our previous program
that we had in last year so the
certificate of excellence is given to
anybody who has over 10
000 points so all of the courses
and the server platform as well as the
codemix logic platform
are connected to each other so we are
able to see our progress
over time and learn more from
you and your activity like what you are
doing and
by that we are able to determine your
progress
and work with you to help you learn more
from
this entire training so we also give out
a certificate of completion
and the minimum requirement for that is
to at least have 3 000 points which is
very easy
you would have to do a few courses and
run a few basic pipelines to get those
points
and then what i have here are examples
from
participants who have already gone
through trainings like this
so urja here you will find your example
under the project example link that i
have shared
she has completed her research project
on differential identification of
biomarkers between neural stem cells and
glioblastoma stem cells
and done that project and is now going
forward and
presenting that project at different
student
conferences and also helping
and working towards her own publications
so these are the different opportunities
that you have so what you do with your
project is completely
open and up to you so you are able to
take forward this training whatever you
are learning through this experience
and then explore the different areas you
can go and apply
for a new position you can start
learning more about
rna-seq you can apply the knowledge to a
project so you have several different
examples of
other participants who have taken these
training and then gone ahead
and applied them one competitions for
example
anurak uh collaborated with arva bora
they both were part of
a training program and then they went
ahead
to win a pool team challenge so there
are these
different opportunities which are
available to you
so you all can go ahead and explore
and now i would want to invite you all
to go ahead
and also start joining us on our social
media so if you're already there with us
linked to our linkedin page and our
facebook group
so let me share the links to both of
these
pages very quickly in a minute
because in our linkedin page if you see
in our linkedin group
then you'll find that there are a lot of
participants who are joining us from all
over the globe so if i
see everybody here there are not only
students who are joining us but there
are also other researchers are also
faculty
so it is a community of bioinformatics
interests it's a community of people who
have similar interests so you are able
to
meet together at one place so this is
the
linkedin group and i'll post it again in
the chat box
for everyone who is interested in
joining
and we also have a similar group in
facebook for those of you who are
interested and i will be posting this
again in the chat box so please go ahead
and join these different groups and now
regarding the question about how to join
this training program
so this is the link of how to
register for this training program and
i'll also explain the different steps
so i'll post the link again in the chat
box here
so if you go to this link you will be
able to find the
different syllabus for this program
it has all the program dates
and the different topics that we have
also covered in this session
and if you click on get started you will
be given three options
and let me explain to you what the three
options are
if you are just a beginner and us just
getting started
with by info matrix and learning about
edges data analysis we recommend you the
beginner option
this covers all the basic training
program
as well as the research projects and
giving your proposal
during this entire one month training
while the
intermediate option comes with one
additional aspect which is
you get mentor support during the part
of the training whereas you can request
one-on-one mentor sessions beyond
a group session so we have these
different dates
as you saw where we will be meeting in
an online class like this
and talking to you about different
topics so beyond those sessions
if you are interested in taking extra
mentor help
you can also go for that intermediate
license the advanced license
is recommended for anybody who wishes to
work
on a project the advanced license gives
you
two months instead of just one month it
gives you two months
which is an extra 30 days access
and you will also get an advanced
license where you are
able to work with your own data sets if
you want
or you're also able to work with our
team of
research fellows as well as our own omix
logic trainers
to work on your own projects so this
will give you the two month option so
these are the different
payment option we will also share with
you
some discount codes which are available
for the program
and you can register for this from right
here
and we also have another option for
students and participants who would
require
some kind of scholarship so we do have a
scholarship option as well
so if you are someone who
requires the scholarship you can also
fill up the scholarship form
at the bottom of the page we do have
some prerequisites
which you need to offer we will meet
with you will discuss
and we only offer these scholarships to
students who are deserving
so we'll have done meeting with you and
will decide whether you
get a scholarship for this training
program
or a discount so we'll let you know as
we do the scholarship meetings with you
so these are the different ways you can
opt for this training program
and once you are in the training you
will gain
access to a page like this it's called
a forum page which will have all the
additional
uh details about how to get to the
different aspects
so this is just an example of what the
forum looks like
it has the event dates it has some
description about the program you will
also get to learn about the other
participants who are
joining along with you we welcome
collaborations and we hope that you are
able to collaborate with each other
on projects on discussing about
different topics
and make it a collaborative environment
and we have a forum option here
so that all the participants besides the
sessions are able
to come up and ask their questions
ask the questions to their mentor team
so that they're able to answer those
questions for you
post any other interesting topics that
you find we also share
the top participants here from time to
time so these are the different
aspects of the training program and we
are also
able to see the different progresses for
different participants who are part of a
training
from right from this organization page
so i welcome you all
again to go ahead and join this
training program i'll be posting this in
the chat box and if you have
any questions please reach out to me at
marketing and find out bio
and now i would want to ask you all if
you have
any questions please let us know
so that we are able to answer those
questions for you
so is there any specific question that
you would want to ask
us or our team here and we can answer
them for
you
so the chat box is open for questions
and
i will also you will also be able to
unmute yourself and ask
any questions that you have to our
mentors directly
regarding any of the aspects that we
were
talking about today so please post your
questions either in the chat box
or let us know
we hope that this program is going to be
helpful for both
students as well as clinicians
and researchers and this is the reason
we have the training designed this way
where we start with very basics
so that if you just have a very basic
idea of
cell in molecular biology you're able to
join the training
understand those basic concepts and then
build up
slowly given with the different tools
and resources that we have shown you
as part of the training program
and i hope i don't see any questions
today
so i want to thank you all for joining
this session
and yes the timing for the program
is 5 p.m indian standard time which is
the same time
as this webinar today so you are able to
see
all of the different sessions starting
from march 2nd
the different sessions all those
sessions will be
on 5 pm uh indian standard time
to 6 pm so if you have any other
questions related
to the program you can ask us again
and thank you all
for joining today so manisha you are
asking can the timing be 5
30 pm isd for now the sessions have
uh already been
designed so if you cannot join the
session on time is there any other
option
of course so what we do is that like
today's session we record
all of these sessions every day and we
have a private youtube channel where we
put it so
only participants have access to those
links
we share it with all participants after
each of the session
is over every day along with the
assignments and
any other details that we have discussed
during the session
so in case you're interested in joining
this training program now
we will keep it open and you can
actually go forward
and join the training session and if
you're missing out on some of the
classes you will receive the recording
for that as it is a one month training
and we'll go week by week so you will be
able to
learn from this different sessions and
you can also review them at your leisure
during the weekends or any other time
that you have
and we'll definitely consider if you
have any other requests regarding the
timing so you can if
a lot of people agree that it could be
done at a
different time then we definitely can so
we had actually done a poll on instagram
where we got this idea that many people
are free at around 5 pm indian standard
time
so we had done that last month and we
got that answer that
a lot of the participants are interested
in doing a session at 5 00 pm
so we asked your community and we got
that answer so we have
designed the sessions to be at this
point of time
but we are definitely open to any other
requests that you may have and we'll try
to consider
them so i hope that we have been able to
answer all of these questions
we'll have more webinars as well as more
sessions
in the upcoming weeks so please follow
the email
which is marketing and find on bio for
any other
information regarding this and i thank
you all again for joining today's
session
have a lovely weekend everyone
you